[Music]
[Applause]
that's a thumbs up to you thank you so
much for joining us here at the break
room
this is new rockstars daily live show
where we cover all the news of the day
that you care about all the nerdy news
live from our very own break room here
at new rockstars hq i'm joined today by
an esteemed panel mr brandon barrett
back in the flat back in the flesh they
tried to keep me down but they couldn't
i paid my bail and i'm free okay wow
weirdly angry way to start off the show
uh and introducing new rockstars very
own researcher anna oh
thank your expectations and lower
[Applause]
my quality couldn't be lower now
and then speaking of lowered
expectations
mr tommy beck told me hey
so great to be back i'm corny
i'm fun and i'm looking for the one so
find me on all major dating apps and
streaming services
today okay great and tommy's gonna be
talking to us throughout the episode
tommy was down with eric voss in anaheim
last week thinking of corny yeah hey oh
uh and thorny uh he was down there for
star wars celebration they got the
inside scoop on tons of big star wars
yeah tommy's gonna be reporting back on
his experiences throughout the episode
uh today we're also we're talking we got
some great marvel news we're talking top
gun maverick huge opening weekend at the
box office we've got a recap of a lot of
the star wars celebration stuff and lots
of other fun and you better believe at
least one person will be doing a tom
hanks as geppetto impression
and you know what if you if you demand
that we do that impression sooner rather
than later you can throw us a couple
bucks in the super chat we're doing our
reverse swear jar today so if we hit a
multiple of a hundred dollars it unlocks
a profanity from anybody on the panel
um i think we'll probably run a poll to
see who gets to use the audience
can i be honest and can i just say
something real quick yeah give me the
camera
i watched the episodes that i wasn't on
i watched thursday and friday
you're all being real stingy
the swear doesn't work unless you
contribute this whole thing doesn't work
unless you contribute you want to super
chat at me you want me to read your dumb
theory
baby
this is why you're still on the dating
app
uh wow i have a girlfriend she just
wants me to seek out new opportunities
three day weekend didn't chill everybody
out okay uh but we're thrilled to be
here again we we appreciate everybody
that's here with us live that's in the
chat who's throwing out super chats much
love to you hope everybody had a great
and relaxing three-day weekend you know
if you had to work this weekend hope you
had a relaxing day at work yeah
hopefully it was it was loud unless
you're a heart surgeon in which case i
hope you focused and tried your best
yeah good point good point uh so let's
get into the headlines
yes look at that nice headlines graphic
oh gorgeous um
first and foremost the big news uh
memorial day weekend box office
dominated by top gun maverick wow which
made 142 million dollars which is wild
to think as long and uh kind of esteemed
a career as tom cruises had this was the
biggest opening ever for
his movie i there was so it at
celebration we're not getting
celebration news yet but there was a
press room and that was the talk of the
room like that all the people from all
the different like msnbc all these other
like journalistic places journalistic
places whatever news sources they're
like this is crazy top gun like his
biggest movie his previous one we've
talked about on the show was more of the
worlds he also they this really broke a
record for biggest uh preview for
memorial day weekend uh opening ahead of
i think it was um
oh [ __ ] well now i can't remember so
it's not gonna happen but it broke
pirates of the caribbean's memorial day
weekend yep and i forget what the
preview movie was if you know put it in
the chat or call in sonic 2. somebody
finally shipped in some big money over
there i can see because it turned on god
bless you
hey thank you though i don't know what
the a in front of it means i think that
means it's a different currency that's
not yeah
awesome i mean uh do you think top gun
got a little uh break room bump you guys
talking about silly tommy and i thought
about it on the break tommy and i saw it
in imax shout out to the fine folks at
imax that hosted us
you if you haven't seen this film yet
it's a fun flick i think it's got a
pretty high approval rating amongst the
new rockstar staff and amongst people in
general you've got to see this and i
mean it's so good you gotta the chair's
gotta vibrate
always oh yeah but especially during
this movie it's like in my house that's
right
[Applause]
uh yes uh so big endorsement hey it's
good it seems to be making a lot of
people happy also fitting for memorial
day weekend that a military movie does
so well thank you to everybody that
served out there we we uh appreciate
your service especially on memorial day
weekend um in marvel news we got a look
at the final concept art of clea uh we
were debating we think it's pronounced
clia i've always pronounced it clear oh
did you pronounce it my uh my sources
are saying
okay john said like clay yeah something
like that yeah clay well i think the
words just fell out of his mouth
the the um
charlize theron played uh oh there
there's the asset um uh character from
the doctor strange post-credits scene
and one thing to note here especially at
new rock stars she's got purple magic
going on right that's a a hue
we've previously seen on agatha harkness
in wanda vision um as part of mt's grand
unified theory of magic colors it's a
it's a dark magic color for sure
she's cool i like her
yeah that concept art looks awesome she
looked awesome in the film he's moving
on really fast yeah we gotta say i'm so
hyped for charlize theron to be in the
mcu absolutely so hyped so hyped yeah
just gotta wait three more years for
that movie to come out oh yeah it'll be
it'll be here before you know i think
three might be a that's short that's not
as soon as it's going into production
um speaking uh in marvel assembled oscar
isaac uh of moon knight fame uh revealed
that the original plan was for his two
main alter egos to have different
costumes uh each time we saw them um
he's quoted as saying uh originally mark
had the mr knight outfit and stephen had
the moon knight outfit then as steven
kind of the character developed and he
became an english bloke in oscar isaac's
words uh it made more sense for him to
be the mr knight character ah which is
interesting those are original
seriously there's something a little bit
of like a little bit milady about that
suit that just isn't really steven to me
but i don't know if it's mark either i
don't know interesting they're so formal
one thing that's really cool about like
those costumes and i don't think you can
really see it on the show it's like
there's a lot of detail and it's not
just white it has like a pattern built
into it uh the costume design i also
talked about when we see uh jake lockley
and he has this like flipped up collar
it has like a very intense pattern on it
that has like mayan ruins and like all
these nods to things in the comics and i
think it's a shame that the costume is
all white because you can't see a lot of
the detail
you've got the great glowing eyes and a
little bit of the stitch pattern on the
the mr knight kevin feige trademark oh
is that true well supposedly kevin was
like
that
oh interesting give it the foggy stitch
or if i came in and said like that's
mine
i came up with that idea no you but you
didn't kevin
i came up with that idea
somebody give this man a giant coat give
me my baseball hat
where's my baseball hat
uh
can we get the results of the swim jump
pole i'm jumping out of my seat oh yes
run that pole we got we got two swears
that we can drop really nearly so now
we'll have to debate whether that means
we need to run two poles to decide who
gets to curse twice or they can go now
now tommy it looks like you're running
away with it i think the folks have
spoken they want you to blast us a good
one and uh drop a little swear knowledge
on us okay i'll see what i can do
because i've been trying to turn myself
around and you know be a little bit of a
better person
listen up [ __ ] oh gosh i've been
waiting a [ __ ] day to get down here
and listen to you [ __ ]
send it in your super chats like some
kind of [ __ ] super nerd i don't care
about your star wars i don't care about
your marvel you know what's [ __ ]
marvelous to me being away from all of
yourself
[Applause]
oh
[Laughter]
i think they're going to run a poll for
for square number two it looks okay wow
though it did seem
it seemed like anna and tommy were tied
i don't know
okay well well they're running another
one they're running okay okay tommy had
42 of the vote uh the previous one
the first time
the people spoke and they spoke loud and
clear i mean you're my favorite person
to get profane with so i i would have
voted for you as well um well while we
wait for the results of that we also got
we got confirmation coming right off of
star wars celebration we got
confirmation for the date for disney
plus day this year it's going to be
september 8th
um and that's one day before d23
disney's annual convention now the
reason that's important is last year
disney plus day we got a bunch of great
trailers right that's when we got our
first glimpse at secret invasion that
was our first look at she-hulk a lot of
great stuff comes out so we'll probably
be getting it's coming out september
we'll probably get some good black
panther
what kind of forever that might be our
first look at the um uh guardians of the
galaxy holiday special and maybe
anything 2023 on disney plus
uh uh armor wars
uh armor wars echo is gonna happen at
some point they might announce some
they might surprise us they might
surprise us with something that hasn't
been you know even announced yet right
we were kind of talking about this
around the office is this
death by a thousand cuts to comic-con
with like wb doing their own day yeah
disney with marvel doing their own day
star wars has its celebration like what
what gets enough to come
down right we said yeah you said that
and then even i mean i feel like the
smaller
satellite cons have gotten so much
better
like in in other cities like phoenix and
chicago dragon con is huge nowadays yeah
it's like they just
they don't and l.a has kind of eaten
itself tens of hundreds of people go to
la's comics there's l.a comic-con and
there's wondercon though to be fair
there are a lot of celebrities that are
like great i can go uh 45-minute drive
or less and do my comic con or
experiences
what why not do that rather than go all
the way down to san diego now
we've all been to san diego comic con
right or at least you know maybe
we're hoping to get there one of these
days guys call in if you know a way to
for anna to get there
you take the five checkline yeah you
take the five down but
i hope it's not gone forever it's a
really good one and i don't think i
think this is a world where like studios
have realized whatever that peak of like
six or seven years ago where it was like
um city of ember was doing a full panel
you know it got so big they were
debuting movies that aren't even like
genre movies right like i think it's
it's going a little bit more back to the
roots where it'll be this the big genre
films will have a presence but maybe
it'll be more about actual comics and
things like that right it'll still be
the figurines the yeah trade paperbacks
all that kind of stuff i mean it's not
like the place we get all the trailers
that's okay let me buy all my gotham
city sirens you know collectible busts
for three hundred dollars
and put them in my secret room my secret
siren room
you know the last time it's not a secret
time
some people call it a kitchen okay for
me it's my secret siren room now now
results are in anna you do get
to use the profanity thank you to people
in the poll what a nice way to welcome
anna to the panel here wow now you don't
have to use it right now it's in your
pocket you can use it now you can do
whatever you like with it
i hope you have a lovely [ __ ] day
what a sweet sweater
they're for you sometimes it can be nice
it doesn't always have to be gasps
thanks to a house at wrong town you know
they did a big super chat
they're australian and they say
australians love swearing i assume
they're australian oh i can't say the
one in australia yeah yeah
and they do and they did it i appreciate
you referring to me as tom de maximoff
not tommy max
whitney and jessica were trying to push
tom to maximoff is mommy and remember
that tommy is mommy zach is zaddy tommy
is mommy oh my god uh and yeah thank you
we'll call out a couple super chatters
thank you for all your contributions mr
krabs saying love the break room try to
make it here every day for my daily nerd
news thank you mr krabs thank you our
friend chrissy now crazy
here almost every day coming with the
knowledge chrissy is a fount of great
knowledge and she's got uh talking about
the mr knight outfit the buttons on the
mr knight suit have the hieroglyph for
consu on them the moon knight armor has
conscious spelled an english letter
erratic on the right side of the chess
piece
wow
that's great thank you chrissy um okay
back to some headlines now this is a
personal favorite of mine we got our we
got the the pinocchio trailer yeah it
came out today it's going to be a disney
plus film coming out later this year i
believe with tom hanks geppetto now we
were debating whether his gepetto accent
is a good accent or a rough accent
why are we not talking about pinocchio
like that's my favorite they barely
showed pinocchio i mean i was free i
will say that of all these live-action
verses they've been doing this one
actually looks like it makes the most
sense yeah in a weird way yeah i i don't
know like
though i mean it will star a cgi
character there might be one reason we
didn't see a lot of pinocchio yet um i
just want to see those little kids turn
into jackasses yeah smoking they better
smoke cigars if they don't smoke cigars
which they're not going to it's disney
now no one smokes anymore they're
turning shotguns into walkie talkies on
the tv but uh i want to see some little
kids smoking you know what i mean i'm
pleasure right and brandon pleasure
island whoa
uh i think it looks great just from the
trailer and i thought i liked tom hanks
you didn't go full girl leto how j house
of gucci now is that what you were
hoping to get from him
i always a lack of my tommy hanks of
performances and a little bit of new
ones
do you think thomas
tom's gonna sing in this
doesn't usually sing he doesn't have any
songs in the animated version but they
usually add songs sometimes in the live
action
uh he's not known to be a
what if he musical
a beautiful voice maybe he does maybe he
only sings in italian like that's his
trick oh he's got an operatic voice
i'm going to see this thing
i think it's just d-plus you can watch
it from the comfort of your own i know
what guy that screams plays
though you got to watch him in the back
alley
about hiding arby's let's get this movie
in theaters guys let's get it in
theaters it might just be homemade
filmsy man
calls him his bang tape anyway okay all
right tommy uh and speaking of uh uh new
releases in trailers we got word we're
getting a black adam trailer next week
june 8th i believe that's a week from
tomorrow um we're very excited this is
the first we've gotten some still images
from black adam but we've seen there's a
little there was that weird mega trailer
that oh yeah yeah yeah he's technically
moving in it but like not nothing from
the movie yeah yes
um so that's cool we have no idea really
so much from this trailer uh get a
little hawkman action a little black
adam
noah santanejo
and you're feeling spicy
yeah yes um so anyway mark your
calendars we'll be reacting to that both
on the new rockstar channel in here on
the break room um also yes we will be
talking about we get an episode of
obi-wan episode three drops tonight
hours away hours we're hours away from
it we'll all be watching that we're
going to have our predictions for what
we're going to see on that episode a
little later on today's break room um
who we think might show up who we think
might get into some fisticuffs oh yeah
and if you've got some big predictions
or questions in the chat throw them in
there
get them in here
a little sidebar with the audience just
like me in the audience real quick
yeah that's i can take a drink of water
i'll disassociate first
camera right here there it is there's
four there's number four hey audience
how's it going
um i know we just met we're a little
unfamiliar uh but i gotta let y'all in
on a little something and i kind of need
you to have my back here in just a
little bit
i
maybe haven't seen any star wars it's
okay it's okay i know that was a really
abrasive statement
um
but i just i'm gonna i'm gonna lie
i'm gonna lie this whole next segment so
i need y'all to kind of have my back i
think we can pull this line off that i'm
really i'm really knowledgeable about
star wars but um
just have my back please okay i know
this isn't the best first impression but
it's you and me today thank you
hey guys we're back technically the
first impression was you tell him to
have a nice f and day yeah so you know
what that was a good first impression
yeah that's true that was true but also
you weren't listening to that
conversation
nothing's right that's right i hope it
was good television yeah is this
celebration i'm sure it was this
challenge
anyways uh we're all gonna have really
thoughtful in-depth opinions about uh
what happened in star wars celebration
hey tommy you just got back yeah uh you
were there last week with eric voss i
was um you saw panels you met a lot of
fans
uh tell us what what did you like what
were the highlights oh it was an
incredible experience uh you know i got
to hang out with my main man pretty
ricky voss and he was a bona fide
celebrity hit that thing shaking hands
it was amazing taking pics some people
knew who i was other people pretended
they knew who i was and i appreciate
those people the most that's right yeah
they put the effort into more pretending
but we had a great time we had
unprecedented access to these panels for
for our channel and for eric and i and
we're hoping it's the start of
an even better uh you know working
relationship with disney uh to get more
content out to you guys and to break
some more stories you know get you guys
the updates as soon as they come in
i gotta say the highlight was the
opening day panel oh my god we got a
john williams mini concert to celebrate
his birthday
harrison ford came out to you know tell
me how much he misses working with me
and then uh and then wish john williams
happy birthday is a bit of an
afterthought but uh
you know i think we've covered a lot of
the news but there are a few highlights
i still want to you know just mention we
did get a little bad news kathleen
kennedy revealed that the donald glove
orlando show is in a standstill right
now just because of how busy his
schedule is yeah so do you think he knew
she was going to say that do you think
she called him out i mean i think that's
we certainly could call that
shots fired no
shots what a good thing that he's too
busy to work on that show right i think
what they're saying is like if donald
glover says i'm ready to make the lando
show no make it happen the show is going
to happen yeah and i would imagine
you know he's not an old man he can make
that show anytime the next five years
and it'll be fine but you know maybe
hurry up
the other big news we got uh which is
good news we got confirmation that
mando's season four is happening and
john favreau is already working on the
scripts so
that is pretty exciting we're still
we're still waiting for three seven
months out from even season three
debuting that's right that's great that
they have that much faith in that
they're already starting work maybe we
get a short gap between seasons three
and four maybe yeah perhaps a short gap
maybe a little maybe the time jump we
thought we were getting
from uh two to three will happen between
three to four because
it would be nice if they like i think
what you're saying is they they come out
sooner but i don't know the way there's
there's just so much content being
banked right now they might shoot it and
then you know who knows pedro pascal
will be 80 in real life but
27 on screen so wow so yeah mando coming
back season four we're happy about it
honestly give me 12 seasons of mando 13
if you ask me 13. baker's dozen i know
that's your favorite show what you were
saying what's that character that you
love from mandalorian oh it's the you
know the one that i can't get enough of
is the one with um
they have more than one eye do you know
the one yeah mostly
yeah broken more than one more than one
yeah that checks out anyway nothing
suspicious about that we also got
uh dueling
bad batch trailers we got one they
showed at the con which i did not see
but tom michaelson uh frequent friend of
the show
was uh gave me the rundown on that bad
bad she went to the panel and then there
was one released online and i guess
tonally they were different one was more
of a like one had full frontal i heard
yeah one was one had dong tongue
the bad badgers being like does yours
look like mine i don't know just joe's
mine they did not make all those clones
equal if you know okay oh boy some of
them matches ain't as bad some of them
carrying howitzers others little pieces
okay and of course we're talking about
the weaponry given out by the empire not
penis size uh and finally last bit of uh
celebration news before i bring this
celebration to an end
obi-wan was reported to be the most
watched premiere on disney plus to date
which is pretty much what they say every
time
we need a catchphrase for this much like
how every actor that has ever appeared
in an mcu or star wars series or film
comes out and the press was like i'd
love to do more right we need something
for like when any streamer announces
this was the most thing ever because i
thought also um i think there was also a
headline that the stranger things
premiere over the weekend for season
four was the most watched sure thing in
the history of netflix it's the
unprovable boast yes yes just yeah
something like unquantifiable i mean
they'll release data eventually and then
we'll all have all they'll never
one just two last quick things one the
ahsoka trailer was incredible that we
got to see during the mando plus
uh
panel on uh
saturday which was a really fun panel
where they just kept bringing out more
and more actors from basically what i
refer to as the mando verse which is
booker boba fett ahsoka anyone that
we've established on mandalorian that is
now getting their own spin-off show that
ahsoka trailer was phenomenal i mean the
being in the room with all these star
wars fans from when that happened was an
incredible experience you just get
chills uh it's hard not to to mark out
as the wrestling fans say now
it was a convention
there were things for sale
and i did bring you all a little gift oh
my god
it's coming out from oh
with an inappropriate comment
anna will not receive her gift uh zach
what got you a little girl oh look at
this
hello pixelated grogo that's a great pin
thank you thomas yes and brandon i know
you love a hallmark one so i got you the
new boba fett real fans of the show know
that this will go amongst my 30 other
hallmark star wars ornaments
you know i got you these free pins they
gave out at disney
wow it's princess leia oh
my gosh
i don't know
i don't know i think she's on the back
oh okay and i don't think the bathroom
i'm pretty sure and then my favorite
thing uh in addition to these very
thoughtful gifts tommy that you brought
back from star wars celebration is that
going to come into play later in the
episode i mean i won't it's not my cup
but there is someone i think we'll be
joined by a guest later i don't know
okay okay
well thank you so much tommy both for
your uh the gifts and for your reporting
back um we're really excited a lot of
that stuff you see you saw in person has
not been released yes right yeah i want
to see that ahsoka trailer eric and i
have seen
a pretty decent amount of mandalorians
uh like an extended mandalorian season
three trailer we saw the uh at the
lucasfilm panel on thursday they showed
us a trailer then at the mandel plus
they showed us a trailer with like an
extra minute and a half of more footage
including so i don't know how much i
don't want to spoil or say things from
the trailer but i mean just incredible
imagery of some locations we've as star
wars fans have been hoping to see for a
long time yeah well i think eric might
have mentioned these in some videos on
the channel but yeah we're very excited
for that footage to get released so that
we can kind of break it down again
uh but we're all jealous that you had
such a great experience and check out
tommy and eric's social media accounts
for a lot of like fan pictures a lot of
folks that took pictures and tagged you
guys
uh
cameraman dashiell sneezing all over the
camera and if the if the image you guys
are seeing is is a lot more boogie
covered right now it's due to dash well
you're in the splash zone
baby and dash now
uh yes earnestly everyone that came up
to us uh
all weekend was very kind very
complimentary very nice it meant the
world to us both eric and i we couldn't
believe how kind and generous you guys
were with your uh time and the fact that
you wanted pictures with the two most
attractive people there dude
but uh yeah that's rosario dawson and
pedro pascal were in the building that's
right
you two are we were taking pics snapping
picks breaking dicks
oh my god and we're excited hey maybe
we'll get out there more there's talk of
us attending the rtx festival in austin
as part of rooster teeth maybe maybe we
might see a comic-con presence from new
rockstars we're trying to get out there
more uh so hopefully hey we'll be coming
to a town near you some combination of
folks you recognize from the channel uh
speaking of things you recognize from
the channel we want to recognize people
that helped us bring this episode to you
in the form of athletic greens thank you
so much to our friends at athletic
greens uh for sponsoring this show now
tommy you literally took athletic greens
with you i did two anaheim i did i had
athletic greens every single morning
they're ag-1 product ag-1
every single morning on an empty stomach
as recommended so you get the base
you get the base nice baby it's in there
and it helps digestion it just gives you
a little pep in your step you know
i gotta say obviously health i'm a work
in progress with my health but something
like this you know it really did it made
me feel better you're in the you know it
supports your immune system you're in a
convention we're in unprecedented times
as we all do yeah
you want to keep yourself safe but it
didn't hurt to have this little green
armor with me at all times so thank you
and it can be hard to eat well while
you're traveling or while you're at a
convention or something like that just
to elaborate uh this does not prevent
covet as tommy seemed to be oh yeah
somebody's gonna be researching soon
okay all right we're gonna be going
right back to right no no don't do your
own research anyways um uh yes you get
the 75 high quality vitamins minerals
and probiotics and lots of good stuff in
here it's like if you can't keep your
diet real tight maybe you're traveling
maybe you just want a little nutritional
insurance for your everyday life
athletic greens is a nice way just to
kind of give yourself that that good
buffer to make sure you're getting all
the good healthy stuff in your diet uh
like tommy did over the weekend yes and
hey right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition just a scoop
uh every day in a cup of water and
that's it you don't need a million pills
and weird stuff uh this takes care of it
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune boosting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com break room
that is also in the description of this
video again that's athleticgreens.com
break room pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance thank you to
athletic greens uh also we want to plug
real quick um the
obi-wan kenobi latest obsession
that is currently available none of us
have one yet because it's so hot off the
press that we do have a a poster that
has the image maybe we'll show off that
later oh oh dash let's get it on the
camera i apologize for everything bad i
ever said about you dashiell um uh that
that design on a cool shirt actually
there's a couple obi-wan kenobi designs
at um newrockstarsmerch.com
the whole suite of uh designs you should
check those out if you uh buy the latest
obsession shirt it unlocks the ability
to get a shout out on wikileaks the
tommy co-host with eric voss you want a
shout out
pony up the doe and get a shirt
i love rex i love mean tommy uh
yeah and again new rockstars merch is a
great way to support both this program
and everything we do in new rockstars
well get yourself some cool stuff to
wear yeah it's a win-win
speaking of wearing cool stuff uh-oh
it's time for mandatory fun
oh no
the station the segment the station
the segment brandon gets to swear the
segment i'm gonna unlock another square
oh okay i'm gonna save him
he's banking
okay listen did you just hit my graphic
again without me asking
again
there we go
the station the segment's so nice that
we play the graphic twice
the segment so important that sometimes
we play the graphic thrice
now
uh mandatory fun is of course back
under my watchful eye where it belongs
after it was desecrated by jessica no
she did a good job i'm just kidding guys
come on not everything i say is serious
i know she did a good job but i do it
better this is something a little
different it's true they're first it
just looks different it just finished
it's just a little bit i just hit
different
uh that's what my little league coach
said let me explain why i wasn't gonna
play in any of the games you're just hit
different son anyway
today we're talking vader because as we
all may have heard
i almost called him christian hayden i
don't know
these i think there's a little vodka
uh hayden christensen
um
he revealed that he worked with a
movement coach to get his vader walk
down right now
this stinks because i was really excited
to do this segment with you guys but i
actually can't
be here for mandatory fun
but i know you just stopped by someone
so let me give just go try and uh
okay somewhere around yeah and that's a
shame because tommy just got back i know
we were so excited to do mandatory yeah
him christian didn't interview or he
said because like he has not really
portrayed vader yeah
a young vader yeah he's portraying
anakin throughout those prequels there's
a lot going on in the background
so to be able to embody the character he
he worked with the movement coach to get
the walk and the movement right
that's how vader that's how vader moves
like a toy he's like a toy well this is
like uh we were talking about like peter
well okay
my name is t michelle beck told and i am
the premier movement and body coach here
at new rock stars oh i didn't know we
had a
movement
model of the year
wow it's skank models oh okay ella's
premiere
low budget modeling agency
no job is off-limits at skank skank
don't trust us
it's a weird
tagline for uh
okay
today we're going
to work the runway okay i want you to
show me your charisma your uniqueness
your nerve and your talent if you know
what i'm saying we're doing vader walks
and catchphrases now michelle will be
judging and the chat will be judging i
have five points to give out the chat
has two points to reward the winner with
the most points will be declared new
rockstars next top vader
i want to see you work [ __ ]
please see the catchphrase see the
catchphrase
what's the catchphrase
i'm really the best leader
now may the best vader win
okay
who wants to go first who's going to
serve me darth vader who's going to
serve me sith i can go first i can go
first all right okay
get out of the way so he can use this as
the runway brandon
oh my vader cape okay it's actually a
jon snow cape but t michelle doesn't
work good on a sure they don't they
don't have to know that and then i'm
going to use my swear that i've banked
first
michelle
here we go this is this is darth vader
one shoulder in a star war what a look
what a love
what a look
hey if this is a [ __ ] counselorship
then where's the god damn ambassador
wow
deep cut quotes
two points for gryffindor oh
five already dishing them out all right
who wants to go next and i want to be
dazzled you know i i i better represent
the star wars fandom because i'm wearing
the pin and everything yes yeah yeah you
love a star wars i'm not going to
represent who will truly okay okay peter
here we go where is it like this
typical yes yes
now this is a girl who knows star wars
i'm sure of it the classic walk is a
little something like
that
oh
okay
to infinity and beyond oh classic
it's giving us cockroach it's giving us
light year it's giving us fits honey
[Laughter]
two points for
you are in slytherin
believe you only have five points to
give out so i think i'm a hard cap at
one i'll make the be the judge of that p
michelle runs on a different type of
courtesy exchange [ __ ] okay here we
go here we go i'm all right
some would argue i could barely normally
walk so
okay watch that chair i see you got your
tuck done yeah that's impressive oh oh
tough place oh give him face wow if
you're not down with me the song that's
playing must be duel of the hates wow
it's giving me clint realness with the
side of uh
sean penn attacking a paparazzi with a
quilting move
three points
three points
now just between us squirrel friends
we're gonna wait for the poll to come
out and that will decide who the winner
of today's mandatory fun is and who will
be crowned with the blessed wato cup who
will take home the water cup and 15 cash
dollars from producer john oh
wow
i don't know if john knew about that a
whole month's pay for john now my
favorite thing this is a real cup from a
promotion when the phantom menace was
released right tommy yeah uh i don't
know who tommy is but team michelle
would like to share that watto is a junk
dealer who lives on a remote desert
planet of tatum
what wada loves haggling and betting on
produ and pod races more than anything
betting on a pod race is how he won his
two slaves which in 1999
was already problematic
but we've got them at the time
the hut lucasfilm ltno this was this was
from a promotion a young brand's
promotion could have bought it could've
been bought in a kfc at taco bell or
pizza hut
combination kfc taco bell or pizza i
would love to know brandon does a great
water impression what what would wado
order at a combination taco bell pizza
hut
give me the mexican pizza but also give
me fried chicken
and we want to thank our sponsors at
taco bell kfc and pizza hut for this
lovely water cup that we got uh just
today brand new right off the shelves
where's the poll at no bpas it looks
like a runaway here folks
uh
anna zack stand before me i've made my
decision oh wow oh okay i guess i'm
standing i just you mean like stand next
to you that's right
anna
you gave us a
cockroach level bug crawl and then a
quote from a different movie
it was shocking it was horrifying you
ate that
zach you brought to us the darth vader
that's been making us
stay awake at night with nightmares of
pure sexual
agony okay the choking was on point
would i rather be choked or strangled
when zaddy's in charge the answer is
both can't go wrong
i've made my decision anna
shantae away
you stay you're the winner
of the break room's next top vader
congratulations to all who celebrate
that's beautiful
thank you thank you team michelle winner
first time
producer john
that wasn't 15. just uh these are three
ones john you owe me you owe me 12
bucks thank you i know he's good for it
i know he's good for him unfortunately i
have to leave i'm late for a horse
funeral oh okay
say goodbye is it karl lagerfeld's horse
okay good to see you thank you michelle
uh what a mandatory fun that was we've
only got a little bit of time left in
the show but we've got to talk about
obi-wan episode three anna's been dying
to talk about it
tonight at midnight that third episode
drops hopefully they'll drop it early
again please do us right disney plus oh
hey sorry guys oh they got your hands on
i got to stop scheduling these doctor's
appointments right before mandy yeah you
love mandatory finances should
everything go okay at the doctor oh we
can talk about it often
let's put it this way you're gonna be
subbing a lot oh no we got a lot of
predictions we want to make for
tonight's episode you guys have a lot of
questions in the chat um
i did see what i love earlier but uh my
main thing i want to know so they teased
this vader at the end episode two right
is he gonna get out of this back to tank
is he gonna be walking around are we
gonna see some full on vader action is
he gonna put on the suit it makes you
think right like in the past when disney
has dropped multiple episodes all at the
same time right like sometimes they do
two they've even in the past they've
done three episode drops
it's often because there's some kind of
a cliffhanger and the next episode maybe
has like the big spoilery kind of reveal
in it after that initial drop so i'm
thinking episode three we see full out
of the back to tank
uh darth not only do we see him moving
around in the all-black i think we're
gonna see him in combat
we're gonna see him fighting somebody
probably not obi-wan but i think we're
gonna see he did get a super chat
earlier that was asking i'm sorry i
don't have the name now but they were
asking about they're they're so excited
to see uh an obi-wan vader dance fight
now that's a big thing right the
prequels is a lot more aerobatic uh kind
of fighting
swirling and spinnings and then uh the
regular trilogy right it's it's a slower
fight it's a little heavier the blades
are heavier uh do you think they're
gonna have like a a a more
entire dragon yeah or do you think this
is gonna transition us into the trilogy
style of fighting that's a good point i
had never thought that like they'll make
it canon by being like oh as these
characters like maybe he can't move net
like vader can't move as quickly because
he's got the robo arms and the robo
right and we've seen this is an obi-wan
that you know has not been in touch with
his force
in a number of years oh that's true he
hasn't been using it as much yeah
yeah
that's true like the arms of vader and
legs
hey i
i don't want to be out of line with you
this is your first show
have you ever seen star wars
tommy
i'm like the biggest star wars fan here
it just it feels you know and i'm gonna
get a lot of heat from this from the
mainstream media but it just feels like
you've never seen a star wars and i just
want you to be comfortable we all wanted
you to be on the break room you're our
co-worker no i get it you want me to
contribute more to the conversation and
don't so don't worry i'll get a little
more involved
back to school back in black vader is
definitely gonna you know i think
they're gonna give the fans what they
want but not too much you know
yeah absolutely do you guys think
vader's gonna have
james earl jones's voice or hayden is
gonna do an impression of james earl
jones because they haven't announced
james earl jones for this do you think
they're gonna is it gonna be an ai voice
and also like why have
so you're just gonna use hayden
christensen to basically be the body
yeah i mean i'm my big question too is
like what does the universe know about
darth vader at this point we're nine
years ahead of uh a new hope when like
vader is probably a more known presence
in the galaxy does anyone know who he is
i mean it's kind of crazy that the third
sister knows that anakin is darth vader
though i don't know how much of a big
secret that's supposed to be or if
anyone cares outside of the 10 people
involved of in the prequels sure i mean
it's a big enough secret that luke
skywalker doesn't know it until it's
revealed right right but did no one
think to just tell him i mean did
everyone know it's like he doesn't need
to know or did they even think that they
were related i know they share this well
maybe maybe it doesn't bode very well
for uh third sisters longevity yeah yeah
i have a bad feeling that that uh that
secret may
go to a
what's the opposite of a watery grave a
spacey great holy grail oh yeah zero g
grave ben mazer asked do imperials have
a memorial day where they honor those
fallen in the death star with fireworks
and lemon sales oh oh wow we've never
seen a war memorial i don't believe in
the star wars galaxy we've seen like
this and there's not we've seen military
like recruitment videos right solo yeah
we saw like an awards ceremony at the
end of a new hope where they gave
everyone except chewie a medal because
they're racist justice for chewie yeah
but i i always do think about like
they're because you know when it was
clones getting killed who cares right
they're just abominations of nature hey
uh
but when it comes to you know uh the the
stormtroopers we know some of those
people are conscripted right yes they
were they were forced to be on that ship
some of those people were engineers some
of those people never fired a blaster in
their lives yep they got blown up by
this awful rebellion wow when is someone
gonna stop these rebels they have to be
stopped uh i wanna shout out a friend of
friend of new rock stars friend of uh a
friend of all of ours and real my friend
of some of the people here stephen ray
morris says i love the whole in our crew
and the work you do each week stephen we
always appreciate your support uh
favorite reveal or moment from the star
wars celebration for me
uh i think you know
the fact that we're getting chopper and
live-action ahsoka and then chopper
coming out and uh you know doing his
thing on the stage the controlling droid
and when favreau brought out uh the baby
yoda puppet that was amazing those are
fun reveals obviously the ahsoka teaser
trailer they've been filming for less
than three weeks and they put together a
teaser trailer that was i don't think
anyone thought we were going to get that
so that was probably not i didn't
realize three weeks and they've already
got some footage wow i got that volume
really cranking over there in marina del
rey that's right i can't wait i'm gonna
stand in line for 13 hours at disneyland
to take a picture with that grogu yeah
oh yeah
we were talking about things that are
slowly rolling i was at disneyland i was
at disneyland on saturday and i saw boba
fett walk around people were hyped for
boba fett yes yeah it was like the
paparazzi was surrounded we were saying
it's wild they got boba fett you were
saying they don't have din jar no he's
not there yet but they've i mean mando
season one game out year i don't know
we've all said that like that caught
them all by surprise they didn't have
grogu pup toys and plushies for like a
year after that part of that too is um
that's why grow goo was such a great
surprise they had not pre-made those
toys we got all these spoilers via toy
releases like thor 11 thunder and stuff
like that none of those yuka prieta said
a super chat i think we won't see vader
fight till episode five or six three and
four will wrap up the inquisitor's story
yay or nay hashtag live long and prosper
i know i think that's a different fandom
and he told me to say that wow
okay
in a confirmed classic star wars
greeting
wait a second uh another prediction for
tonight speaking of grand inquisitor
do we see the grand inquisitor in
tonight's episode yes we saw him
take a saber in the gut but you think
he's alive i think i think there's the
you know there's two theories going
around that are uh appealing to me for
two different reasons one is that that
wasn't the real grand inquisitor the
grand quizner grant inquisitor but that
there's that vader has actually cloned
all of these inquisitors and like
there's they you know you can roll them
out like django fett
you know trooper clone troopers the
other thing which i think is more likely
is he's going to get the fennec shine
treatment and just get like you know
gutted the robo guts friend of the
program uh thundercat
or whoever the empire equivalent of
thundercats yeah yeah lightning cat
lightning yeah uh i like the idea that
like the third sister is good enough
with the lightsaber she missed all the
vital orchids here i mean just did it
just to like be an [ __ ] about it yes
which i like i wasn't supposed to say
[ __ ] i apologize that's okay well
we're only
28 minutes away
or twenty-eight dollars from nerd
goodness swear nerdtacular had an uh a
great
rogue prediction we're going to see the
grand inquisitor and darth vader share a
bok to bubble bath in the shower
and we're going to get this line this is
a line that we're going to hear tonight
this is guaranteed from nerdtacular i
find your lack of bubbles disturbing
force is strong with that bubble you
heard it here first there's only one way
to make bubbles in a bathtub and it
ain't pretty oh
okay
i like that well i do love the idea i
mean that's a little bit of a jokey
prediction but you do pull back from
vader's back to tank and you see a
second tank with the grand inquisitor in
it that'd be pretty cool it's just a
back to spa i mean there's also like a
fun contrast one of those guys is well
they're both super pale white and black
but one of them you can see your head
the other one you can't uh chrissy had a
great question and she wanted me to
answer this before so we'll get to it
real fast uh what would akbar feel like
if you touched him akbar i think is like
cold
a little damp but not sticky or slimy
he's just cause he's like a catfish
she's called a dip and then she also
says can you force choke yourself
and why do jedis wear
why do jedi's wear battle skirts instead
of comfy pants to fight in setup of a
joke why do you think his pants oh
battle skirt just kind of the long tail
they have like kind of that tunic but i
think i think they have like leggings
underneath right because you don't want
to flash i mean you're you're many
sabers ninjas and samurais obviously
jedi is highly inspired by eastern
culture right originally they both
both traditionally samurais kind of have
a long thing and that was for kind of
like armor i don't know a lot about
samurai culture but like they they're
kind of tops went beyond the waist right
yeah they have like a little
little skirt like this
the ninja ghee or whatever again i'm not
an expert but like you need that belt
because your top kind of goes down a
little bit farther yeah maybe it's not
so much a skirt it's just a long shirt
like a night shirt it's like a cargo
pants for your top oh yeah yeah and you
get more extra pockets way more pockets
functional functional
uh okay oh wait a second
this is this is huge for us
we got over four hundred dollars wow
i think you can take us out with a
crypto okay later and thank you i think
it was our friend mo who pushes over the
top with fittingly the super chat that
said swear zaddy swear yes i just want
to tell the entire audience i got a text
message from my mom last week asking
what does zaddy mean
um
the tell us in the chat what's that
she's been watching the show she's
confused by internet culture in general
but certainly this particular branch of
internet culture i had to kind of
explain it to her in a way in which she
wouldn't google it um and so it is with
that i bid you all [ __ ] ado uh
i hope you have a great [ __ ] rest of
your day until we [ __ ] see you
tomorrow
thank you anna next time we have you on
we'll talk about a fandom in which you
know a little bit more less about yeah
oh less okay yeah we could aim for that
too yeah but uh we appreciate you being
here thank you to everybody that watched
we'll be back tomorrow and and we'll be
talking about that obi-wan we'll still
definitely talk tonight we'll talk some
stranger things this week yeah i know
everyone's been asking about that
there's a lot of hours of that show to
get through so um hopefully we'll i'll
be finished with it maybe in the next
couple days and we can talk stranger
things uh and then we got miss marvel
and the boys
right around the corner so we'll be
talking about both of those in the next
few days we are bringing the boys
underground back baby
has
you're gonna be involved tommy yes um so
thank you all for joining us uh on the
break room have a great day everybody
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
boom
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
you